Mariah Carey and her backup dancer Bryan
Tanaka have called it quits ET can't
confirm the two have split I don't know
what the relationship actually is ET
spoke exclusively with Mariah's ex Nick
Cannon about the whirlwind romance
so was the relationship all just for
show I thought it was bizarre somebody
watching from afar I thought the show
fabricated a lot of stuff
the reported reason for the break-up
Bryan was only after her Fame and was
jealous of Nick most men are jealous of
me I'm joking
but now I mean I know nothing about him
yeah at the end of the day she's an
amazing mother and we we focus on our
kids that's never gonna change no matter
who's in my life or who's in her life we
we have kids together so we'll always be
family et has reached out to Mariah's
reps for comment meanwhile Nick is busy
filming the 9th season of his MTV show
wild and out they started off as a place
where me and my friends can just hang
out and have fun
Kevin Hart David cent music dude was
going on to do amazing things in that
career we're like the longest-running
comedy show ever on MTV and it just
feels it feels great
[Music]